north korea is one of the most isolated
states in the world for neighbouring
countries it's considered a threat for
the people who live there that means
famine constant surveillance and strict
rules
chihun park has now escaped north korea
ceiling chai is south korean raised to
hate one another they met in 2014 in a
chance meeting and have now forged a
friendship and written a book the hard
road out telling the story of two
koreans
thank you so much uh both of you for
joining us today it's really great um
to meet you both and and for you to tell
the story which i hope viewers will find
interesting um
you've just published a book uh the hard
road which you wrote together which
tells the story of of your life chi hung
uh but before we get on to how we met
you met
um and the collaboration can i start
with you uh you now live in berry with
your family
but that's not where your life started
was it what was it like
growing up in north korea
oh when i lived in north korea i didn't
get any informations from outside
countries so
we didn't know too much about what
happened in outside the country so in
north korea is called their socialism
country but that is not true that is a
totalitarian
dictatorship country
so every morning we wake up same times
it's 5 00 a.m you know there is a in
apartment is a captain shout the doors
wake up so so almost like being in
prison in a prison race that's true that
is 21st centuries
is prison in north korea and also modern
slavery lives in north korea nowadays
when you were growing up there though
you said that it was very isolated you
couldn't
you didn't know what was happening
outside of north korea
did you feel unhappy or did you just
accept that that was your existence that
was your way of life
because we are slavery so celebrities
never talked about the future or next
moment or something that so we always
are happy with the government it's
not personal happiness it's always his
political happiness something happened
to you and that you wanted to
escape you fled north korea what what
was the thing
what happened in your life that made you
think i have to leave
very very few people ever leave
north korea and come to tell a story do
they so how did that come about that is
my father's courage you know that my
brother had been lawyer is a workers
party in north korea and
he always duty and respected to
government and he also talked to us when
you grow up you also joined the work
party and respected
your regime but
this 1998 last time during this at the
oldest march and three million people
died of starvation
yes yes i mean and my uncle also died of
stabilization in front of me
and yeah and my younger brother had
these problems so my father last week
was save your younger brother so leave
north korea so that time i didn't
understand why
but
that is my father's courage bring to now
there's my politicians so so you fled
with your younger brother
because of the famine and your
other brother said you must leave the
country your uncle had died so you fled
to china
basically because you were fearful of
the famine and that you would starve yes
yes
so you didn't flee for political reasons
you fled for survival
then what happened to you in china once
in china it's language also different
but i never talked about the language
problems first i met that is the korean
chinese people and
he lives in not his biggest
houses is a kind of is poorest is
bungalow but they have lots of rice eggs
and meat yes so he gave to us this nice
meal yes i was shocking because
socialism country is a great country but
china is not a socialism country but
these people is always full mountain
very quietly
they had much better food than you yes
yeah yeah but then you you had a child
in church what happened did you have a
child in china or you were sent back to
north korea what happened to you because
it was the first memories a chinese
person gave to us a nice meal but not
all people nice and nice us yes so then
i was a human trafficking consultant
chinese men you were so yeah how old
were you that time i was 29 yeah
so
this is not only is my experience that
is all north korean female and girls
experience and this is nowadays is
smokeless human tropicals they awaiting
the border areas kidnapping females and
the girls and so you
you were trafficked you were sold to
chinese men and you became pregnant yes
yeah and then you were sent back yeah to
north korea yeah so uh my child was born
in china and he was a statelessness
child because chinese government never
accepted to her to him in china and so
they never gave to them identifications
so my son was never being told did he
come back he didn't come back with you
to north korea yes yes because he was
born in china yeah he's not original
north koreans so i alone sent back to
north korea because chinese government
never accept refugees in china
that's all for and i think people can't
imagine what's happened inside presence
when we sent this political it first
resented secretary president camp and
we went to today and they post this body
searching which is off all cloth clothes
and the body search it and that is not
the female guy it's mayors and then
you sent back to north korea and you
escape you escape for a second time yeah
how does that happen what happened um
you know the first time i lost all
family members my brother died in north
korea and i lost my younger brother too
and i still don't know that my younger
brother survived or not
so i lost to all family members so my
child is my own family
and i am mother i have a duty to save my
son so your son is in china yes sir my
son is done you've been sent back to
north korea and you get back yes sir
your goal now is i'm going back to my
baby
yes so in prison i only talked about my
son so i just used survival i have to
survive and one day united my son let's
come back to the two of you now
um
celine you are
south korean
you're together you've collaborated on
this book
um how did how did you meet and how did
this collaboration
come about
um
the
the moment i met her
was
quite extraordinary we met by accident
i was hired by amnesty international
to translate
an interview
because they wanted to do a documentary
on her life
and um
just to give you a little bit of context
um i grew up in south korea
because my elementary teacher told me so
that north koreans had
red horns on their head
that north koreans were
evil
communists therefore dangerous
and
when i found myself sitting in front of
her like this
here i was thinking
what am i doing here
how am i going to um justify this to the
korean government
mind you the two koreas are still at war
there is a national security law
in place
that prevents us from engaging with each
other
i have to report myself to the south
korean embassy otherwise i'm going to
get into trouble so all kind of things
go through my mind so you initially felt
quite hostile is that fair to say you
felt hostile oh it's more than hostile
you were free i was afraid
i was uh regretful that i was there
i was shocked just the stories that
she's telling you today the story in and
of itself is shocking enough but then
um
exponentially uh shocking for me because
i had to digest what was happening to me
given the background i grew up with yes
my father was a south korean diplomat
yeah so you had to completely
recalibrate everything everything that i
was told
was all of a sudden
completely also
so you were fearful of retribution from
the south korean government both oh it's
fearful for both what do you think what
were you inside
north korean side fear would happen to
you well the south korean side i i
wanted to make sure that i didn't do
anything against the law yes you would
be an and the north korean side well
north koreans you know is it though
north korea is the same we this is a
hostile to south korea and america
the pubs of this book um
is telling your story but
i mean now you've explained that to me a
south korean and north korean writing a
book together i mean that blew that one
apart didn't it i mean so that's quite
politically
for people in south korea that that's
this is a massive deal it's right it's
only a very difficult um situation to be
in
but um
uh so
apart from that original trauma
um
with time
not that i turned the page ever
this woman changed my life eight years
ago
so i never turned the page but um
there was this
desire of
finding out why is it that i was so
um
so shocked by this event what is going
on
it gave me the envy of exploring a
little more
this nonsense of two
korean women speaking the same language
looking alike
eating the same food living in england
raising families we all do similar
things
and yet we were supposed to be enemies
yeah so i needed to dig into that
three years along the line after some
couple of random meetings she approached
me and said would you like to write
my story finally there is a line at the
end of the book without giving too much
away
that says your story is proof
that there lies a deep desire for
reunification
of north and south career do you think
to each of you do you think in your
lifetimes you you might see
live to see united career
i would like to say that not knowing the
answer to that
at least there are things that we can do
to prepare for an eventual reunification
and
england is actually probably one of the
only places in the world
where we could be doing something about
this because as you know there are about
800 north korean refugees living in the
uk
about 30 000 south koreans
and um we we can
practice
living together
and chihuahua what do you what do you
think about that i mean you grew up in
north korea now you have kim jong-un
do you ever see a world where there
won't be a a totalitarian state in north
korea can you
can you imagine it or do you think it
is impossible to achieve my hope is now
is because britain is joined the korean
war
so britain is still the empowered
country and distill the power so british
society have been teaching again to
people how is communism and socialism
is what is affected our society and they
destroyed our freedoms so that is could
be changed our
mind first and then people truthfully
looking for what's happened inside north
korea
yes well look hopefully your book the
hard road
will begin to tell that story and people
will read it and better understand
the divisions well thank you both for
coming in and talking to me and thanks
for telling me that story it was really
a pleasure to meet you both thank you
thank you so much for having us